Let's go next to our caller from the three,
four, seven area code. Who's calling today
from three, four seven.
Hi, David. This is Katie from calling from
Florida as well.
Hey, how are you?
Can you hear me? Yes, I can. I do. I, uh,
I had a question. I guess there's not really
a question today. I just want, want to conduct,
give my opinion. Also, I do applaud guys with
witness bringing this up again because you
had a discussion with this one. Uh, just on
the previous caller. I mean with the police,
previous caller about Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren, this current tobacco that they're
involved in. So in my opinion, I feel like,
uh, Warren, uh, if you're an honest and decent
human being, I think you should just come
out and just, you know, put it on and just
tell the, you know, uh, the people, Hey listen,
he said this, he said this in, in this particular
context and the fact that the warrant, uh,
the fact that Warren isn't doing this is kind
of disappointing to me. And I know I was a
big Warren supporter as well. You know, boonies
obviously is my number one choice. I, you
know, I'm very progressive but you know, Warren
is probably number two. I would still vote
for her, but I, I feel that it's, it's really
disappointing that she's not really coming
out. Uh, and really just, um, clarifying the
contents of what Bernie said.
Yeah. Because here's the, here's the thing,
you're doing it. There has to be more context.
Like we, we, you know, Elizabeth Warren is
a, is a 70 year old woman who's speaking style
and thinking style. We are familiar with Bernie
Sanders is a S I think he's 77 or 78 he's
a 77 78 year old intelligent man with decades
of public speaking and thinking extemporaneously
on the record. The idea that he would cryptically
say, I don't believe a woman can win and there's
no other context and there's no understanding
of what he's really saying by that is is laughable.
There's just no way that the conversation
is that simple. And that's where I get to
Elizabeth Warren when she has confirmed that
he said it, she has notably said nothing else
and it would be eras. It is irresponsible
not to say Bernie said, I don't think a woman
can win. And what I understood that to mean
was he doesn't think women can be president.
Right. If that's because that's what's being
implied. But there's no way in hell that that's
what Bernie said and therefore it should be
clarified. Bernie said, I think given the
political environment and Trump being president
and sexism, that a woman wouldn't win in 2020
I'm not saying he said that, but the point
is there. There is obviously some additional
context that would immediately dissolve this
controversy, which Elizabeth Warren has not
put forward. And I believe that she should.
Yeah, it is. It's this appointed anal idea.
Other things that, you know, they're both
progressors I get it. They're both running
for the same democratic nomination. Uh, but
you know, the ultimate goal is there. They're
actually good friends and they share a lot
of common policies and, you know, she just
should, she'll come down and support, I mean,
not support him, but just, uh, you know, uh,
clear to record and, uh, it's just one that
she's not doing it.
Yeah. And here's the thing, here's the additional
thing. If, let me just say one more thing.
If she truly believes that what Bernie said
was just a sexist attack on the idea of women
presidents, she should say that the fact that
she hasn't and is allowing it to be implied
inferred by some people is, is a very wrong
way to go.
Yes, absolutely. Uh, I completely agree. I,
well, we'll see what happens. Maybe I'm speaking
too soon. Maybe she will up with the statement,
but as of right now it is a little bit disappointing
to me because I was a huge one fan. I like
to prove his quality that I would still vote
for her, but it is a uh, you know, disappointed.
[inaudible] my call. I am a big hand to show
thank you and keep it local work. All right.
Thanks so much. Great to hear from you. That
does it
for calls today. I apologize, I was not able
to get to everyone. I never end, but I do
the best I can. We will take calls again and
I look forward to hearing from many more of
you next time.